[موسيقى]
لكن انا ودي انبه الى شيء طول العمر وهو
لك بعض الناس الحقيقيه يعتقد او يعيد
التميز الحضاري ان كان تميزا حضاريا في
الجزيره العربيه الى كونها الى كونها فقط
ممرات طرق لا انا ارى انا لا ارى ذلك
لاطلاقا ال ال الممرات الطرق هذه نعم كانت
تمر بها لكنها ليست الاساس في بروز
الحضارات يوجد العربيه الانسان
نفسه الفكر الذي يتبناه هذا الانسان
المنطقه الذي الذي عاش عليه هذا الانسان
هو الذي بنى هذه الحضارات وهو الذي بنى
هذه المراكز الحضاريه المتميزه والمدن
والممالك المتميزه
[موسيقى]
يؤلمني عندما نقول بان والله مدن القدس
اخر استطاع ان يجعل
في التاريخ القديم وفي الحاضر وان شاء
الله في المستقبل
الى درجه عاليه من الرقيه
[موسيقى]